oh this is everything I bought in the
film this was such a fun sequence to
work on it let me tell you what is
really great about this shot welcome to
another episode of VFX artist reactor
and jump right in with one of the most
famous visual effects shots on the
Internet alright let's see it
hey what's up Andrew Kramer here for
Video Copilot dot next talking about
great tutorial why are we doing two
toriel's I thought this was for like
movies and whatnot
TV shows maybe this is just bad honestly
why do we why are we doing this what's
going on guys what do you uh what are
you doing oh hey hey I think your
renders done yeah yeah I think he's
right this is pretty bad hey what's up
Andrew Kramer here and welcome back to
another very exciting episode of VFX
artists react we have a very special
guest today Andrew Kramer from Video
Copilot dotnet one of the most legendary
visual effects artists on the planet and
he's gonna be sitting on the couch with
us today reacting to other movies and TV
shows the visual effects wasn't there
great or bad or whatever we're gonna
talk about we're gonna break him down
I'm very excited to check out the show
in person let's jump in
that shot what he bust into the Oval
Office against everybody just so good
this is one of the coolest scenes pretty
much ever how do you guys think they
pull this off with like with having a
guy be there that not be there than be
somewhere else and not be there so I'm
on a bet
Nightcrawler himself has never actually
in any of these shots yeah I think that
probably makes most sense he's probably
the green screen element another
interesting way they could do this is
with like stunt doubles so one guy does
the shot here in the kick and then they
cut over here that's a different stunt
double in that way you could sort of
have that continuity of action well like
take this couch shot right he you know
flips the guy up if that is like a stunt
man he could just do the effect and then
just jump down behind the couch and hide
and then you could paint it out just a
couple of frames what do you think
they're doing frog was like crazy like
atmospheric smoky effects every time he
teleports so it's probably like a really
high particle simulation but it is
really nice the way that the color of
his jacket sort of comes out and those
those particles that are close to him
you can see like when he teleports
there's like a secondary animation that
happens like the particles move or
another simulation on top of the initial
one yeah this was a really popular
effect when it came out I remember
people asking about hey how do you do
the Nightcrawler effect another thing
actually that I realized that it's
probably a CG tail that was just
wondering about the tail that tail has a
personality especially when he grabs the
knife and he gets shot as like the best
visual effects happen when you're
practical elements and your your CG
elements are tied together as well as
possible if you have no practical
elements your visual effects don't look
good even if you need to do something
with a green-screen don't do everything
with a green screen because you'll be
able to get more believability if
there's something really tangible in the
shot
just watch and tell me if you guys
notice something weird I tell you guys
see anything weird you see it are we
looking at the fire it's hard to catch
catch what is there a flicker you could
say that we're getting some frame frame
duplications as you're going frame by
frame
oh yeah that one made it into the final
movie no wait wait hold on but it's just
the debris that's missing here yeah this
couldn't have been on the VFX house
there's no way that you guys are
misunderstanding Magneto's power so
here's what can happen in a shot like
this at the end of a movie anybody who's
worked on visual effects knows that when
the movie is locked it's just like a
vague way of saying the movies not
locked with so much crazy stuff going on
it could exact shifted one frame or
listen renders fail and that one shot
didn't get rendered mistakes happen
everyone makes mistakes we make tons of
mistakes all the time that we're all
human even the big-budget movies we
didn't even notice it it's not like
we're out making houses or something
dangerous oh yes I know this shot okay
this the shot continues to blow my mind
to this day wait so there it is there it
is boom that's magic
that's the magic right there I remember
taking the VHS of this while I was in
high school
and playing it back and just having my
mind blown just the cinematic importance
of this shot what exactly happened here
we're looking at her run up the stairs
and the camera is tracking with her okay
yeah and then at some point we're behind
her the camera is now behind her over
the shoulder
that's when visual effects shots are the
best is when they are straight-up magic
tricks and you just slept on oh wait
what look at the end of the shot it's
not just a throwaway my storytelling
right there how did they do this this is
a shot I really
dug into like the behind-the-scenes but
how do you guys think they did if you
don't know alright so they probably had
some sort of double watch your hand
reach out it doesn't look like it's
perfectly in sync I think I see it I
said I'm gonna throw this guess so right
now it's just a shot of her cameras in
front camera guys running backwards
filming her mm-hmm straight forward
right so now what I think they're doing
is they have another shot that gotten
they went up to the mirror like with
green screen behind it and they're
pulling back from that at roughly the
same speed they were going down the
hallway and all they're doing is then
compositing the footage they have into
that spot and thankfully their motion is
kind of lining up so that's just footage
for reaching up the knob in this
real-life version now look at her
pointer for example her hand position in
the mirror is different than her hand
position in real life that's not an
actual reflection of her that's just
another element for reaching for it so
knowing how this shot was created you're
exactly right yes there's no mirror in
the shot at all yes green or blue over
where the mirror would be the most
believable part of this entire shot is
the smudge is on the actual mirror you
can actually see you know how mirrors
have that little yeah edge that kind of
creates a slight angle shift on the
refraction so what they've done is
they've done a distortion over the plate
that's behind it so that it looks like
it's behind that glass you see how it's
like yeah I'm refracting that edge right
there it's the best thing about visual
effects it's storytelling visual effects
coming together making something that is
even better
[Music]
so let me set this up okay so Air Force
One Harrison Ford present in the United
States the airplane is running out of
fuel and they need to get off the
airplane as fast as possible before it
crashes into the ocean now unfortunately
there's some problems and so of course
I'll get off your plane the summersault
here at the end it's tough it's I would
say the problem
the water is not high resolution enough
it looks very misty very smoke like
right here and it sort of miniaturizes
the effect I think the visual effects
industry has gotten so good at water
splashes and huge scale of water
simulations that when you see this sort
of smoky looking water it's lacking any
detail but actually the plane actually
disappears a little bit so you can see
the horizon oh you can see the sunset
but you can't see the airplane in there
it doesn't help that the shots like two
minutes long yeah they look at this
stuff probably in the same way they look
at their own shot and think the amount
of time it will take to pull that off
versus the other 20 shots that have to
get done and there's a definitely a
balancing act to doing this oh man
alright we're talking about that force
awakens now why might this specific shot
be special to us Andrew I and a team of
hologram artists helped to work on the
sequence you see here this was such a
fun statement to work on I worked on it
with some really awesome people so this
is my favorite part of the shot right
there where it's like that tiny little
thing and expands out into this really
high detail thing that fills the whole
room we built it as a single element
mainly because in the shot it has to
come out and then it has to expand if
you see some of the planets have a
little bit more density so we use like a
additive material so that it feels a
little bit more thick little hotspots
that are out of focus yeah I'm loving
that out-of-focus bokeh they're
anamorphic yes they used a lot of the
original lenses when you film with an
anamorphic lens you're sort of squeezing
the
image through a lens to fit onto a
square piece of 35 millimeter film and
then it's being projected sort of at a
two-to-one ratio and when it gets
stretched out because of the way that
it's filmed you get this sort of taller
looking bouquet element rather than a
round bouquet element you guys know that
you can add depth of field and post
using plugins and depth we want to have
that nice little stretch so that it
matches the rest of the film one of the
things I got to give a shout out to is
the team doing the 3d match moving on
all these shots like look at this shot
what are you tracking I'm tracking the
oxygen the 3d tracking process involves
analyzing 2d points across an entire
sequence and then from those 2d points
you sort of recreate where the camera is
based on how those points would be
visible if it was really shot through a
camera I usually do all the camera
tracking here it's like okay I'm gonna
stay here for a day and just track
dozens of points manually nothing is
more special than receiving a project
with perfect 3d tracking day all I can
say is I have a real appreciation for
everybody else's brilliant visual
effects work being analyzed by people
frame by frame if you guys are wanting
to see us react to any like clips or
movies that you know are your favorites
or like good incredible shots or even
into like shots and it looks so good
please leave a comment below it helps
give us ideas and inspiration for it we
can talk about in our videos and here's
enough of that back to the clips
but why is there a dinosaur in the
temple after coming out of temple if I'm
honest I don't quite remember it being
as ridiculous the only thing I feel it
really technically falls apart on is the
comping of the people into those shots
so this is what we would call like a 2d
shadow that you would add on to sort of
imply lighting nowadays they'll actually
have objects on sets to block out the
lights here you can really tell that the
Lighting's actually not changing on
Adrien Brody at all they're just moving
like a shadow a mask around him yeah to
try to give the effect like it looks
very very fake I'm just gonna go out
here and say I'm not a big fan of this
movie I think it exhibits a lot of the
same problems that the Hobbit exhibits
Peter Jackson it's a lot of time on
moments that he gets been a lot of time
on overindulgent use of visual effects
can be in its own way a form of bad
visual effects I mean Peter Jackson made
the Lord of the Rings trilogy and
frankly you know what yeah I do whatever
he wants you can have a few Branagh
sources it's okay
dude I love the tennis day like for the
longest time was like my favorite movie
hands down same here this is everything
I bought in the film Jeff Goldblum times
good old crowds running yeah that looks
like real fire cuz it is real fire did
they just kill a bunch of extras what
they actually did is they built a
miniatures and they turned the whole
thing sideways lit the explosion
underneath and fire rolls up through it
but you're filming it from that
perspective so it feels the fires moving
sideways God brilliant
super cool is the exposure of the fire
correct for what we should be seeing on
a street no they had to shoot that fire
in slow motion they probably had to
stuff down the aperture of the lens to
get everything in focus so that makes us
so that everything's really dark so even
though the fireball is incredibly bright
it all shows up exposed but if you're
shooting at night any sort of fire is
gonna be so bright it's gonna clip the
end result I think is worth it because
you see like the really good detail of
the fire itself it's definitely a
stylistic choice getting hit by debris
space to read look out oh no my
spaceship if there's ever a movie to
watch the theaters like this is it I
want this in the theater and it was in
this amazing fake and it looks so real
the spacesuits aren't real the
spacesuits there are entirely CG and the
actors are in like a kind of a fake
spacesuit that has like tracking markers
on it - I get the motion right but it's
crazy how realistic it looks like the
spacesuits do not look fake whatsoever
in fact after the fact like I thought
the spacesuits are real and they were
just comped in like everything else
around the most fake I didn't know just
the faces were real and that was it so
even though this looks incredibly
realistic technically in outer space
would not look nearly this good the
ambient light in space there is no
ambient light you have the harshest most
direct lighting you can possibly have
because the only light that you're
getting is from the Sun so anytime
you're looking at like the dark side of
any of the people here you wouldn't
really be able to see it you know a
little bit of creative license it just
makes the shot a little bit more nice to
look at yes detail to anyone who's ever
like getting individual
and you don't know where to start
literally go to Video Copilot dotnet
slash tutorials and watch every video on
the website Andrew here's I've done
something very special for visual
effects artists across the world that's
sharing knowledge and techniques on how
to do this stuff with your home computer
what a positive wholesome message is a
positive take away I thought we're gonna
trash these if you guys would love to
check out Andrews work of course is a
YouTube channel Video Copilot but also
Video Copilot net definitely go check it
out if you guys like what you're seeing
on this channel please consider
subscribing if you're not already you'll
be notified of the next videos that come
out and it helps us out in this whole
game we call YouTube mine yeah what were
you thinking man he was sitting right
there the whole time